hello everyone and welcome back to the
opera euro rapid we are in the knockouts
the first round of the knockouts the
semi-finals as the the preliminaries are
over and it's master versus student yet
again magnus carlson faces daniel dubo
uh so without further ado let's check it
out as it's quite uh quite a
lovely short game uh for you to enjoy uh
so magnus in game one has the white
pieces
and he opens with e4 sorry about that
uh we have e5 by dubof uh knight to f3
by magnus knight to c6 and
bishop to c4 so of course you're going
for you know what uh but here
uh we have knight to f6 dubo doesn't
even give magnus the opportunity to go
for the evans gambit now unfortunately
so he
goes knight to f6 uh we have d3 and the
bishop to e7 so just the two knights
opening
uh we have castles and the d6 by lube we
have c3
so pretty much standard stuff here
castles and the rook to e1 and here h6
are preventing the bishop from being
developed all the way
so knight beat the d2 the knight going
on its usual journey to g3 and then
maybe to f5 in the future
uh and here dubo goes for bishop to e6
this is
a very very rare as the white will have
a lot of counter play
against the black's doubled e pawn here
and it's questionable whether black will
be able to use the f file
uh for the rook all that much so here
bishop captures with f captures and now
knight to f1 by magnus and now there is
one game where knight the h5 was played
in the database but here do both plays
a5
and it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how how the game continues
magnus goes
nice to g3 so just continues his
development
the pawn here now does prevent the
knight from reaching f5 so
it is a bit of a change in the position
so
a4 and double grabs more space on the
queen side and now
bishop to d2 magnus just continues
development
we have d5 now and d5 is a
again a really wonderful dubovian move
uh as it
uh offers this pawn and then uh for
forces a capture because uh
if magnus goes for this for example
captures captures
it's hard to say what dubo had in mind
here yes his king is a bit more active
but the d spawns are now extremely weak
but magnus not really interested in
going uh
into dubose full on preparation instead
he goes for
b4 so just says i'm not touching that
i don't care what you have prepared so
here we have eight captures on b3 alpha
song by do both eight characters and
rook captures on a1 we have queen
captures and now
closing the position with d4 now
preparing the captures and then the
queen will be able to gobble up the c3
the d3 pawn so here queen to b1
defending and also
uh ready to push b4 if needed in the
future
d captures bishop captures and now
bishop to c5 so now you can see that
opening up the f file is a bit uh
scary for white as there could be a lot
of pressure on this f2 pawn here
so here b for by magnus bishop to b6 and
now even b5 pushing the knight away
knights to d4 and now we have bishop
captures on d4 by magnus if he goes for
this knight captures an e5 move then yes
he grabs the pawn
but dubo has a lot of tricky moves here
such as knights to h5 just
offering a knight for this queen to g5
and then it's
uh definitely black who's who's
attacking here
uh and uh magnus again not interested to
find out what's happening here if
captures capture so the both knights are
now under attack you go back queen
captures here
and it's not a not a bad position for
black so here magnus goes for bishop
captures on b4 instead
we have bishop captures not going for e
captures e captures is sort of
an improvement on your own position
because you undouble your pawns but you
lock out
this bishop out of the attack so it's a
case of uh
you know improving your opponent's
position by improving your own efficient
uh
position very rare in chess so instead
after bishop captures on d4 we have
bishop captures by do both
and now comes queen to b3 you could
capture once again
but after captures and captures it's
again going to be a good position for
blacks
because there's a lot of pressure on the
f2 pawn you could easily shift the
attention to the d3 pawn so not
not something you want to do so instead
after bishop captures on d4
queen to b3 magnus goes after the e6
pawn
and the queen to d7 noob of defense uh
we have knight to f5 now
possible as the queen is spinning the e6
pawn and now
knight to g4 do both just ignores the
knight as it's not really doing anything
here
but now it actually is doing something
so here magnus goes for knight capture
sunday for e
captures and now this extremely
important move e5
you want to keep this pawn here as a
target and you do not want to allow
something like king h7 and d5 because
then this pawn becomes stronger
and so on and now magnus has the idea he
wants to play queen c4 and
pile up on the c7 pawn as it's uh
it's kind of a backwards pawn you're not
going to be able to advance it because
the white spawn will be ready for
capture so here
h5 by double trying to create some
weaknesses on the king side also making
room for the knight here on
h6 then the knight can come to f4 f5 and
so on so here
queen to c4 going after the pawn here
preparing rook to c1
and now uh while you could play
something passive like rook to d8
defending this pawn
uh so then rook to c1 comes and then you
don't really have a way of defending
both pawns
here duboff goes for the very active
move from the thumbnail
rook captures an f3 and now uh uh
it's uh well anything is possible now uh
magnus of course has to capture the root
there is no other option here
knights the h6 as uh dubo made it
possible by playing h5 so
the rook uh the exchange sacrifice was
very well prepared
and now rook the c1 magnus shifts the
attention to the c7 pawn as he doesn't
really see what
dubo wants here on the king's side so
knight to f5 by duboff now preparing
some knight
h4 to f3 ideas uh and the magnus says
all right that's uh i mean that's way
far off i'm just going to capture
the c7 pawn so queen captures on c7 and
now comes queen to d5 by dubois and here
magnus went into a into somewhat of a
deep think as
well it is a very scary position and if
something like
queen captures knight h5 knight h4
happens it's going to be very very hard
for white to defend
now here you could go for something like
b6 uh but uh
it requires uh too much calculation and
it is a rapid game
you don't want to allow do both to spend
too much time calculating is he's much
lower in time so here
the point is if you capture you have
this queen to d8 check and then you
shift the queen to b5 king h7 queen g5
and now you've defended everything and
the black doesn't really have all that
many options if you capture here white
captures here with the check
and aside from that you know the rook is
free to roam the c
file so there is no good way for black
to continue this game
so instead after uh queen to the five
magnus goes for queen to c2
but now double just goes knight to h4
and now there's a lot of pressure on the
f3 pawn
queen to eq by magnus he goes on the
defensive now comes
knight captures on f3 and here you don't
want to go king to f1 because then again
knight captures and h2 comes with the
check
so uh king the h1 by magnus uh boldly
goes where where no king has gone before
uh in front of that queen but the thing
is there aren't
all that many great discoveries here
here duba picks up the pawn with
check knight captures on e5 and now
knight
and now pawn to f3 by magnus uh saying
that okay you're welcome to grab this
pawn as well here if knight captures uh
on f3
uh magnus would just play b6 as again
there are no good discoveries here
there's not
much you can do but i guess it was
possible maybe to just start pushing you
start pushing and you know
good things will happen uh but okay
however after f3 dual decided to capture
the b5 pawn now he says
all right if i uh can survive this i can
then maybe start pushing the b
pawn i have a lot of uh counter play for
my sacrifice to exchange but magnus just
played
rook to e1 he now has a double attack on
this knight on e5
and dubo now has to figure out what to
do if you move the knight and queen
captures and e6 comes with check
and then magnus slowly starts collecting
so duboff picked up the pawn on d3
but this just doesn't work because i'm
sure you know what happened here without
even pausing the video
here magnus played rook to d1 and now
there is no saving the knight the knight
cannot move otherwise the queen falls
and if you do nothing then just queen
captures
wins the piece and of course the
position is now completely winning for
magnus but the duval was extremely low
on time here i think he finished the
game with some two seconds on the clock
so yeah he played a lot of these moves
that were being very low on time
but that's uh you know how it is
interest you have to always be mindful
of your over your clock
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it
i would like to thank duncan brown mario
gooda mr pasta services anthony ricci
and preston lerner for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
most likely with a game or two between
these two gentlemen uh to see
what will happen uh you know uh
throughout their match
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day